προποκοθήσι και επιλήπαμε στην αρχιότη μιλάδαι και σπάνεια και μέσα από μελέντη που έκανα για
κάποια στιχία για άλλες ενδιαφέρουσες και άλλες ενδιαφέρους εσπτυχές της ζωής σας κυρια πίτα μια
πα αυτή είναι και χμι βλέπω εδώ εργαστήρία χαρακτηρισμούτε έχνις αντρέα σπίτας και έντρο επιστύεις
και δεχνολογία στα ρπιολογία κι τον πολιτισμό τοι τίλδο κύπρο τι σας όθησε να υδρισε
τα κάστηρια και πιες σημαντικές ανακαλύψεις ήρθαν στο φως μέσα από αυτά καταπρότον πρόεπει να
πω ότι το υστητούτο κύπρου στο ιστηττν κύπρου ίμαπό το ένδεκα και ειχ τν τιβή
αναλάβω την εκτελιστική επιτροπή είχα αρκετές ρκετή συμβολή λεγα το ιστητότου το βρήκαμε σε δύσκολους
καιρούς και τώρα όπως α έειαπουςη έχει αναπτυσεί όπως πρέπει και αναπτήσεται ραγβαία το εργαστήριο
αυτό το οποίο χρηματοδότησαείναι πολύ σημαντικό ια την αρχιολογία και για τα έργατα δικά μκιέργα
ξνα παραδήγματος χάρι γίνονται έρευνες για ται σύκώλες που υπάρχου στικύπρο μπορείς να ορίς πλύκλά
τη ακριδή ιλικία μιασικώας είτα μετρο στιλικία του ξύλου ίτ των χροματισμόν και τον χρομάτ
ο περιέχει αλλά πέραντουτο μπορείς δουλέψεις